c'est une tradition ici dans les
yvelines depuis 19 ans le medef le
principal syndicat des patrons organise
son université d'été ici sur le campus
hec paris à jouy en josas
mais concrètement à quoi ça sert à
informer a informé par les médias parce
que la presse vous êtes là la presse là
ça donne le ton de ce que veut faire le
medef
et puis encore une fois je vis pour nous
adhérents sa fin de rencontre et
d'échangé autrement que dans nos
commissions autrement vraiment de plus
convivial
cette année sept mille cinq cents chefs
d'entreprise ont fait le déplacement
jusqu'aux yvelines pour assister à 12
conférences sur les thèmes de l'économie
de l'emploi et de la france des
rendez-vous qui ont permis aux
entrepreneurs de se réunir pendant 48
heures des conférences qui sont toujours
intéressantes parce que l'idh ouvert
l'esprit ouvrir le cerveau pour écouter
effectivement ce qui se passe à droite à
gauche est toujours intéressant surtout
quand des choses sont dites importantes
comme tout à l'heure sur les
contractualisations du travail qui sont
des sujets qui sont effectivement durant
ce moment qu'ils sont importants
nous voilà tous ces choses là sont
importantes écouté il n'y avait pas que
des entrepreneurs la sphère politique a
également graviter autour de cette
manifestation neuf ministres se sont
rendus ici à jour josas on peut noter
également la présence d'élus yvelinois
je tenais à travailler avec le medef 78
j'avais pas encore rencontré et on a
passé une partie de l'après midi
ensemble un cassandre d'entrepreneurs
hier c'est essentiel de créer une
routine avec eux donc une fois par
trimestre on puisse se voir et qu'on
puisse challenge et les projets du
gouvernement les attentes sur le terrain
l'événement également permis aux
syndicats ouvriers de se faire entendre
dans le seul deuxième jour du rallye du
médoc
une manifestation qui a réuni plus de
centaines de personnes avaient organisé
parce que nous avons rencontré un acteur
ça fait plusieurs années qu'on le fait
cette année c'est un peu comme l'année
dernière on est dans le même contexte où
l'année dernière s'étaient la loi elle
comme ricky se préparait aux cours d'été
là cette année c'est un peu particulier
puisque il ya là les ordonnances qui
sont en cours de rédaction sur la loi
travail
prochain acte du rapport de force entre
les syndicats le patronat et le
gouvernement le 12 septembre prochain
avec la première grande manifestation
nationale contre la réforme du code du
travail